すき家の牛丼は
週何で飽きるのか
１日目の朝でございます
飽きる自信はないんですよ
ずっと食べ続けれるんですけど
さすがに、一週間も三食を
なるべく全部牛丼にすると
果たして週何で
牛丼は飽きるのかっていう
ちょっと、自分への挑戦でございます
一週間全部行けたら
週２１すき家になります
いただきます
美味いんスわ...
美味いんスよ
美味いのは知ってる上での挑戦ですからね
今回は
ご馳走様でした
こっからすよね
どっちかというと
１日目の２食目です
牛丼でございます
いただきます
全然アリ
ご馳走様でしたー
まだ全然大丈夫です
問題ないっス
味も美味しいですし
牛丼に対する飽きる要素もございません
では
三食目、夜でございます
いただきます
ご馳走様でした
三食目から味わえない肉本来
噛むことによって生じる
肉にある味の旨味
コクが
噛むことによって感じることができます
ちょっと何言ってるか分かんねえな
おやすみ
いただきます
ご馳走様でした
週７の牛丼でございます
いただきます
ご馳走様でした
行きたくない
(笑)
もう行きたくないよ
いただきます
ご馳走様でした
週１０目です
いただきます
さすがに週１４となると
肉の旨味っていうのを完全に分かりきっている
自信があります
味の性質っていうか
すき家の牛丼ならではの
特徴
いただきます
ご馳走様でした
週１９です
いただきます
週２０回目ですいただきます
すき家生活
週２１回目に
やって参りました
ここまで作ってくださった
全国のすき家で働いてる皆様
いつもご苦労様でございます
いただきます
最後までうめーわ
本当に
うめーわ
最高に美味い
ご馳走様でした
太ったかな？
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓
もぉ↑　や↑し↑も↑やぁ↓しぃ↓
も↓や↓し↓もぉ↑　や↑し↑も↑やぁ↓しぃ↓
も↓や↓も↓やぁ↑　もぉ↓や↓し↓　も↓や↑も↓やぁ↑しぃ↓
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑やっ↓
もっ！もっ！やっ！しっ！♬
♬♪♬♪♬♪♬♪